joining me now texas lieutenant governor
dan patrick dan
venezuelans now crossing the border now
you have
people who are convicted murderers child
molesters
and yet the bite administration
essentially saying we got it under
control
yeah it's it's it's unexplainable
unless you accept the premise that they
know exactly what's happening and they
want it to happen
because that's the only way you can
explain it they can't be this ignorant
to what is happening so they
they see it they just don't want to
acknowledge it think about this a moment
laura about 60 percent of the people i
was told today that are coming in
through the del rio sector which is a
small sector very narrow
are coming from venezuela 60 percent
they're flying from venezuela to mexico
city or cancun
or to um monterey mexico and then they
bus
in so we now have a whole different
class of people different set of people
some of them are much better dressed
than others not all
but this is a more educated class
leaving fleeing their country
uh in in with other people who else have
we caught this week
people from south africa from haiti from
ubekistan
they're coming literally now laura from
all over the world why wouldn't they
why wouldn't they i mean the
administration says come on in
and then we we're hearing from people in
new orleans
raymond's report that he just did and
you have people on the streets in new
orleans like
wait what about what about the american
people it's not that we don't have
feelings and and we're concerned about
everybody
but we have a we have an american
problem right now
with what's happened to this with this
ridiculous
prolonged response to the pandemic and
locking kids into school
with out of schools and so forth and now
i guess all of humanity is going to show
up and
just walk right in uh laura we are only
three weeks from the end of session but
we had
a meeting today with the legislature
and we are going to put in significant
more money
and i can tell you this right now
tonight we're going to put in
significant more money
into our border security we already
spend
close to 400 million a year of tax
dollars we shouldn't have to spend
to protect taxes and and to protect
america at the same time from the
criminals coming in
we're going to significantly add to that
we're going to have more personnel
we're going to have more assets on the
border we're going to do everything we
humanly possibly can
in texas because the border patrol they
are demoralized
um they are now uh taking care of
families and kids and not doing a good
job of keeping people out yeah and
down del rio the sheriff down there he's
overrun his jails are overrun
it's it's a disaster design
dan i got you know i was down in del rio
back in may of 2019
and we thought it was bad then we were
down there and they were it was right
before they
i think they instituted the return to
mexico policy it was
just starting to get going i believe or
right before
it was bad then okay biden could turn
this around overnight with the mexico
policy reinstated that trump
created well and dan uh finally you know
when you
when you see how this is all enriched
the cartels they make thousands of
dollars
uh if you had one word for the
administration's response here what
would it be
uh the one word is it's disgraceful
and you are allowing people to be
enslaved uh you're
you're creating new inventory service
and you're putting people into
the section well leave it at disgraceful
dan thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else